60%. HAS  PUBLIC HEALTHPROTOCOL
CELEBRATIOS EE ON
YOTHIS IS I A PACKEDMPHITHRT. R.
NEARLY A HALF A MILLION MOTORCY
FLOODED INTOY
DID A CO OAT A TRUMP RALLY. ONL
I AMODAY IS BECAUSE
LIBERALS HAVE BEEN BUSYME IE A'H
BUT LET TEL MTHHAPPY, BECAUSE T
JOIN USHIMOG,SHINED. NTESUTH DA,
MY JAW D.YOU SA
HOSPITALS BEING   IN,
EY HOR T YETHEY
N'VIYE, THE HARDEST
CH IS THAT PEOPLEARE STILL LOOK
ANSW AHEY DON'T W TO
BEE  CREAL.
THEEADID IS T I
PAS A
CULMINATION OF SLE
AND THEIR LAST DORDS  BE
IT'S NOT REAL.
WHEN THEY SHOULD SPENDING
TIME THEIR ANDHATRED A ER THOSE
IVING END O AN
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE THERE FO
WHENOUSON WITH , YOUR FERYO  AUT
CALLVAPOTHERM MIGHT BE 75, NOTH
.AND IT JUST MAKES YOU AND MARU
OW YEOING T
COME BACK ANDO IN. YEAH, KIN
>> HOW COULD IT NOT M YR
OWN HEADPING BREATH,
THR DO WRONGTH I THINKPL
FOR ANYTOPLE WANT IT TO BE ITEU
THINK IT MIGHT BEUN ER MEAN,
-
FAR-FETCHED.
TH SINCENE THIS AREA 'V TOY, IF.
TELL Y THAT YOU HAVOU OS C PPL
THEIR CARE AND VERYAT
BUT RTUNAT T
WHAT I'M REMEEAT
REMEMB
I WAO REMEM SAVES AND
THE NS,EMBERING CHILLING ON THE
COUCH THE OTHERIG MY
DOG WAS NOT THAND IT'S SO MINDNT
THINK THAWOATHER AIS L
YOU'VE SAID THAT -- I QUOTE
YOU FORTEN F'ing
THAT YOU LIVETO OYO  GH IO I PR
F-BOMB OTHT HOW
YOU FEEL.
IT IS L
MOVIERE THEER
ROLL OVER D IT'S HSAD,
EVERSPNURSE,
EVERY DOCTOR IN THIS STATE ISEIS
SIC IN THE SA YOUREAT THEM IN
SAME WAY, THEYIE S IT
AGAIN.
AN THANKFUL FOR THE WED ALONG
THE WAY AND WE'RE DOING A GOOD
TAKING CARE OF THE PPLTHE'REAGI
OUR PATIENT LOADS
T'
SOMETIMES IT'SOUO  BUTTNOW,
YOU SAID JUSTS YOURT
SH, 5%RATE.
I , OUR ENTIRE STA HAS 0,DO THE
MATH ON T FOR HOW MANY OF US
ARE >>H,RD THE ARE SE THEY'RE
ONSE? THINK FRUSTRATING A
HEALTH CECAUSE
THE LAST T T ASK HEY SEE CARETH
J TO HELP.AND I'T
FROM TPUBLIC, AS FAR AS
WEGCING,
THE T
INTERNET RIGHT NOW THAT SAYS,
I'OUE OF
DEFENSE, I'M YOUR LAAN ACTUALLY
AND THE THATEWITH
ITME
AKING.
BECAUSE THEEALITY IS
THE TOWN HAS 650
0THOWNMAP.PEOPLE, W GO TO
WITH,URCH, OU'VE EV HTND YOU H
DEATHS THAN YOU HAVNTOWN?YEAH.
IN S SOUTH , I
HAVE I HAVEN'TOO IN THE
LAST FEW I THINK 68 ONHA T LIVES
PERSPECTIVE,PLE WLIHATMONTHS,HA
LED 20 PELEE AEERE.T WE HAVE  M
ROW.AND IT'S NOTETTINGBETT NUR
ALARM.
THANK YO T DO
FOR YOURPATIENTS, EVEN
THEY SCREAM AT REALLY ARE BACEV
AGAIN.
AT